- [Gary] Which means
I over-invested.
More people,
more capabilities
because I'm gonna
take the whole fuckin' pie.
(triumphant rock music)
- What if I told you this is the
last Monday morning
of your life?
- [Woman] You're still
recording, right?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- [Gary] It's so weird how the
world's going now, right?
We're like...
- Okay, so, worst advice,
what is the worst advice you've
received along the way?
- Almost anything
everybody's ever told me.
I mean, advice is bad
unless it's contextual
and you really dig deep.
I give very little advice
to my employees
until I really start to
get to know them.
The advice that I give them
comes with really
getting to know them.
Emily's advice got
better every day
because I got to
know her better.
And so, most people like to
give advice without context.
The best advice only
comes from the people
closest to you and
the ones that actually have
your best interest in mind,
not their's.
That means almost nobody
because that means
everybody's on the outside
and a lot of times
the people on the inside.
I mean mommy and daddy
are giving you advice
in their best
interest not your's.
- So how do you differentiate?
- I just don't
listen to anybody.
- Has that come back to
hurt you in any way?
- I'm sure.
But I'll take where I'm at.
- Great.
- Thank you, guys.
(laughs) You can't put it
out there but, you know,
anyway, this was super fun.
- Thank you.
- Let me know if I can
be a help. Bye guys.
Take care, good luck.
- See if you have time,
call (censored).
- Okay.
You know it's one
of those classic when
they do something it pops
up a different way, right?
Yeah but unlike me,
you're an attractive woman
and that gives you
8 billion shit things
that I don't have to deal with.
No, you have to understand,
Facebook allows for AMA,
everything does.
Twitter's the
water cooler of our society.
I know you get it
'cause you're fucking smart.
I know it sucks but
it's just gonna,
you put a finger
in that hole and
that water's gonna come
somewhere else.
We need to attack
mental health and other issues
and many other issues,
racism, equality,
more meritocracy and capitalism,
but in a different way.
There's a million
things we have to do but
I promise you
shutting down Twitter or
forcing real names on
Twitter is the furthest thing.
You're trying to fix the faucet,
the problem is
in the well, my dear.
("Summer Over" by JMKM)
Oh, no way.
- Great space.
- [Gary] How cool is this?
Right?
- On record about
you're going to
steal the whole
entire game in town.
- Like I'm a polite guy.
I don't want them
after the first taping,
everybody's like the
three of them being like...
We're about to launch
something called VaynerTalent.
It is basically this.
It's what I believe is the next
version of production companies.
It's the human
production company.
It is the combination of
influencer social media
marketing and reality TV.
It's the unique thing
that I've done that
nobody's done for the
last six months.
It's the reason that
even though I've been
the best at this
craft for nine years,
that over the last six months
everything has changed for me.
I've got it figured out.
I've built a team around it.
I've taken my members and
built a division around it
and we're gonna do it.
And I, so, I can take any
B-list celebrity you have
and make them A-list and
I'm being dead fuckin' serious
with you right now
for $25,000 a month.
Dead serious.
Alright, I'll see you
in a few minutes.
- [James] They told me I was
meeting with the big dog today.
(group laughs)
You're going in Gary's office
you're meeting with the big dog.
- Top dog. It's a
better way to put it.
Around, I have a
vision for education.
Which is unbelievable.
- [James] Wow, Gary.
- Uh-huh.
- [James] Come full circle.
- No, it's just
I have my version.
I believe in everything just not
the way you guys want to do it.
Here's what it's gonna be,
7 to 11 P.M. night classes all
hands on, one shot, go.
That's it. I'm gonna
have my version.
- [James] Okay.
- But it's gonna work.
It's gonna (censored)
be the point person for
(censored).
Team that's gonna
create the ACC, AE
what it means to
be an account person,
we're going to literally change
the company in five minutes.
- [James] Yeah.
- [Gary] Let's put
this up there too
next to that. We're gonna have
to move that one over.
'Cause it got centered.
Put this one, too.
Alright, ASAP.
Alex doesn't look like
he's doing anything.
Alex, can you hang this
next to that thing, fix it.
(DRock laughs)
I trust Alex more.
He's not doing anything and
he looks handy as shit.
Cool.
- [Woman] Who's that? Your face?
- Yeah. I need way more of my
face around this office.
I think, let me give you some
really good advice.
When you win on a macro level,
don't over-stress
the micro level.
There's unlimited opportunity,
it's just priorities.
It's a macro thing. You know?
As long as I'm not stressing
about the micro,
you shouldn't stress
about the micro.
I'm not so sold you aren't
better off to go take the jump,
fail and come back then to
wait a year to take the jump.
I don't know.
You're doing all the right
things 'cause you're being
respectful as fuck and really
trying to be careful here
'cause you know
I'm the insurance policy.
So I'm just not so sold
that you shouldn't jump,
yeah because you'll come back,
right now, you don't know.
And it's fucking eating you.
You're better off to go, fail or
first of all win, easy, right?
Fucking yes.
Fail, get that nut off,
come back for three years
and then try it again or
come back and never
try it again but
boy, will you know a lot more.
- [Man] We're catching
up maybe 20, 25.
Circle, I'm talking to you
because I'd love to be able to
say to our clients that we can
do their social media--
- You don't want
to send them to us?
- [Man] I do want to but you
weren't interested before.
- [Gary] Buzzfeed?
- I had just texted you.
- [Gary] Okay. I don't
have a phone anymore.
- Got it. I got a new phone.
- And I texted you.
- [Gary] About?
- Something we
should talk about.
- [Gary] Right now?
- Not now but soon.
- [Gary] Alright, I want
to know what it is.
You guys keep talking.
(somber music)
You know what the best part is?
How awesome it is that
the whole thing is recorded
and if they want to take
it in the wrong direction
I'm thrilled to put
out all the content.
- Great.
- Hello.
(group affirmation)
- [Gary] So, I'm really thinking
that Q&amp;A is the way to go here.
- I'm never on defense.
I'll bail, I'll bail.
When I when I was dating,
if I saw anything
that wasn't in,
if I dated,
so I hate negativity.
It's why we
have a great culture.
If I dated a girl that
I realized very
quickly like she liked,
it was intriguing
to have conflict,
I literally bailed
immediately.
Out forever.
I have no effort
for defense.
I'm trying to win
every game 477 to 433
and I'm talking about baseball.
You know what I mean?
- [Man] I don't watch
baseball but yeah.
- But you know what I mean?
- [Man] Yeah.
But baseball where
there's lower scoring.
That's why that's the analogy.
Fucking soccer.
I'm trying to score
so many points
that I'm not worried
about the casualties.
You know this more because
you've been at Vayner
like I never care about
the failures at Vayner.
I love when people
come in to me and be like,
"Listen, I've got to talk
to you about this problem.
"It's really gonna
undermine us."
I'm like, "Are you
a fucking idiot?
"How the fuck you
think we got here?"
If you want me to
play your micro game,
I'm gonna look
like everybody else so
I'm always on the offense,
always macro and
always very aware
of what I want to happen.
We're gonna make less
money this year at $100 million
than we made last year at $67.
Net. I don't mean percentage.
Net.
Because I'm getting greedier.
Meaning they're in trouble.
Them.
(group laughter)
I see it which means
I over-invested.
More people,
more capabilities
because I'm gonna take
the whole fucking pie.
I care about capitalism and
meritocracy and the game
more than I care about myself.
And that is crazy shit.
And I really don't see it,
only 'cause I haven't
gotten close to it
or figured out how
to see it in others
but it is a different thing.
When you get to that
level of selflessness,
it's a vulnerability
that is so extreme
and it's so interesting.
I just think I'm cut
out for it and
I don't want to force
my audience into it
because their behavior probably
hasn't been their whole
life to be in it. Got it?
("Always" by Jura Kez)
Tyler, did the email to
the company go out?
- [Tyler] It did, yeah.
- [Gary] Good.
99% of the market is short term
and the 1% that isn't
and has the talent
wins every time.
Which makes no sense because
unless you're gonna die
you should only play long term.
There was a stat that some
dude in Mexico City said
one of these futurist type
characters. I'm sure he's smart.
I have no idea who so I just
but he was right before me
as I was mic'd up and he says,
"It's been
scientifically proven,"
"that 85% of what
"humans make decisions
about is irrational."
And that spoke to me.
Because A,
I think it's higher and
B, it's why I think all my
success is happening.
I am stunningly the most
rational and the most practical
of all yet, I don't seem it.
And when he said it I'm like,
"Right, that's why."
"Because the rest of
the market is irrational."
DRock, there's war time generals
and there's peace time generals.
(light music)